this video is kindly sponsored by keeps
find out more later on hey 42 here what
if i were to tell you that right now
this second you're only able to access a
tiny fraction of your true mental
ability that a well of untapped brain
power is waiting just beneath the
surface of your consciousness and that
one day soon cutting edge technology
will allow you to unlock it
turning you into a genius
overnight don't worry i'm not trying to
sell you anything i'm just outlining the
basic premise of a widely held belief
that we humans only have access to about
of our total brain power
you're probably already familiar with
the idea since it crops up in popular
culture all the time it's the basis of
dozens of novels and several popular
films
but
is it actually true
to find out i'm going to need the help
of one of the greatest geniuses in
history
a man with a giant hole in his brain
and a bunch of blind fish
intrigued
excellent
let's begin
i want to take a moment to talk about
hair loss because i've had people close
to me start to lose their hair as early
as their twenties
and it's always an upsetting experience
if you're in the same boat then you're
not alone did you know two out of three
guys
will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
but the best thing you can do to prevent
hair loss is take the initiative now and
do something about it whilst you've
still got hair left i like keeps because
it makes treatment super easy by
delivering your hair loss medication
straight to you every three months so
you can say goodbye to awkward doctor
visits and waiting in pharmacy checkout
lines there's a reason that keeps has
more five-star reviews in any of its
competitors and hundreds of thousands of
men trusts them for their hair loss
prevention medication so if you're like
me you're probably not ready to lose
your hair just yet but prevention is key
the faster you act the faster you'll see
results and the sooner you start using
keeps the more hair you'll save
so if you're noticing that you're losing
your hair do something about it for a
limited time go to keeps.com forward
slash 42
or click the link in the description
below to receive 50 off your first order
check it out
the idea itself is thought to have
originated with the work of harvard
scientist william james considered by
many to be the father of american
psychology
whilst he never put an exact figure on
it james was a big believer that we
humans are only able to tap into a small
fraction of our true mental and physical
abilities
and it turns out he wasn't the only one
a student of his at harvard by the name
of boris cedus was firmly of the same
opinion
boris cedus and william james were close
so close that when boris had a son in
he named him william james cedis after
his professor and mentor
who was also the child's godfather
and the tributes didn't stop there
because boris realized that his infant
son represented an opportunity a chance
to test his mentors theories in the real
world
boris reasoned that if he raised his
newborn son in just the right way he
could help that child to access that
deep well of hidden potential that the
vast majority of the general population
is unable to
if you've been following my channel for
a while you'll already know where this
story's going because i've talked about
boris's child on here before
in my video about the greatest genius of
all time william james cetus didn't top
that list but as you can probably guess
from the fact he was mentioned in a
video dedicated to history's most
brilliant individuals
boris cedis's attempt to unleash his
son's hidden potential was wildly
successful
as for just how successful well some
people claim that william james cedars
had the highest iq in the history of
mankind
somewhere between 250 and 300
that's high enough to make einstein look
like homer simpson after an eight pack
of duff light
einstein's iq was around 160. as well as
that startling iq william cedars
attended harvard at the age of 11
a record at the time and spoke around 26
languages one of which he'd invented
himself at the age of eight
so
yeah when a couple of eminent
psychologists raise a child specifically
to harness the parts of the mind most of
us never do
the result was a boy with an apparently
superhuman intellect
and i have to admit that's some pretty
compelling evidence that most of us only
use 10 of our brains right there but is
that it case closed end of story does
william cedars prove that
like old iphones our brains are being
artificially slowed down
well
not exactly
because putting cedars aside for a
moment
when you think about it it is actually
kind of hard to believe that our brains
are somehow perpetually underclocked
i mean
like
why
like every other animal on the planet we
humans are a product of evolution
now i'm the first person to admit that
evolution has a habit of working in
mysterious ways
i present exhibits a
b
c
and d but still if there's one axiom
evolution almost always seems to abide
by it's this
use it
or lose it
that is if an organism stops using
something that adaptation will
eventually degenerate until it's no
longer there anymore
we see this in nature all the time take
cave fish for example as the name
suggests cave fish of which there are
more than 200 species live in caves deep
underground where no sunlight ever
penetrates
as a result many of these species no
longer have eyes
evolution by natural selection has
simply done away with them
as creepy as that may be from an
evolutionary standpoint it makes perfect
sense functioning guys offer absolutely
zero survival benefit to a fish living
in perfect darkness
in fact they're actually kind of a
hindrance
because growing and maintaining guys
takes up a lot of energy that could be
better used elsewhere as you may know
the brain is the most energy-hungry
organ in the human body
despite only making up around two
percent of your total body weight your
brain uses around 20
of your daily energy intake
not only that but we pay a pretty big
price for having such large brains
they make childbirth extremely dangerous
both for mother and baby have you ever
noticed that most animals seem to have a
much easier time of it than humans when
it comes to giving birth
yeah
blame your massive brain for that
by some estimates just a few hundred
years ago before the advent of modern
medicine
the lifetime risk of a woman dying in
childbirth was as high as 4
the equivalent of 1 in 25 women dying
whilst giving birth
by the way i should point out that not
all animals have straightforward methods
of bringing their young into the world
female hyenas for instance
give birth through their clitorises
sometimes referred to as a pseudo-penis
causing them to rupture in the process
i know
horrific isn't it
sorry about that
anyway it simply doesn't make sense that
we would dedicate so much energy to an
organ the brain that's so massively over
engineered for no obvious reason
meaning if we really did only use ten
percent of our potential brain power
evolution would have selected for
smaller less energy hungry brains
way back in our distant past the reason
it didn't
is simple
the idea that we only use ten percent of
our brains
just isn't true
in fact it's quite spectacularly not
true
even something as simple as opening and
closing your fist
involves actively using far more
than 10 of your brain and i'm afraid
there isn't really any room for doubt or
debate in this one
imaging tools like pet and mri scans can
literally track our brain activity
showing us that beyond any shadow of a
doubt that even in sleep our brains are
a hive of constant activity which
probably shouldn't come as all that much
of a surprise really after all our grey
matter isn't exactly short of things to
do there's all the fun stuff obviously
like interpreting sensory data from the
world around us
solving complicated problems and coming
up with terrible puns
but there's also plenty of boring
maintenance work to be done
like monitoring and regulating the vital
processes that keep us from
spontaneously dying from one moment to
the next
the funny thing is despite being
complete nonsense the 10 percent myth is
remarkably widely accepted
for example according to a 2013 survey
65 of americans believe it to be true
that's more than believe in evolution
even more alarmingly a 2012 survey found
that around 50 percent of primary and
secondary school science teachers in the
uk and the netherlands
also believe this myth to be true
and they should definitely know better
of course the media has a lot to answer
for with this one as i mentioned at the
start of the video the 10 myth crops up
all over the place in popular culture it
was the basis for the film limitless
starring bradley cooper and it fulfilled
a similar role in lucy starring scarlett
johansson
that one was particularly egregious
because the character tasked with
explaining the whole 10 of the brain
premise was played by morgan freeman and
it's a well-known fact that human beings
are pre-programmed to believe everything
that man says
but it isn't all morgan freeman's fault
part of the reason the myth gained
strength particularly in the early days
is because neuroscience was very much in
its infancy at the time
and there was a lot of uncertainty about
which bits of the brain did what
as you've probably already noticed the
human brain is a pretty remarkable thing
this one odd little organ that looks a
bit like a mouldy cauliflower
is responsible for the world's tallest
skyscrapers for men walking on the moon
for harry potter aeroplanes microchips
blue tack and well everything if you
were to take whatever device you're
watching this video on right now and
shove a metal spank for the middle of it
there's a fairly good chance it wouldn't
be much good for watching youtube videos
on afterwards
the human brain on the other hand
is much more resilient
allow me to introduce you to phineas
gage
in 1858 phineas had an accident at work
where a meter long iron rod was blasted
through his skull with such force it
exited through the other side and landed
25 meters away
despite this catastrophic final
destination style injury
gage survived
in fact he didn't just survive
he recovered
and hey if you can blow giant holes in
the brain with relatively little impact
on overall cognitive function
it isn't such a huge leap of logic to
assume that large parts of the brain
don't really do all that much which was
pretty much the view of many early
neurologists
these days we know better
whilst gage did make a full recovery
well until he died from an almost
certainly related epileptic fit 12 years
later
reports from the time showed that he did
suffer some fairly dramatic changes to
his personality and since the iron rod
that pierced his skull is thought to
have pretty much obliterated his left
frontal lobe a part of the brain
containing the prefrontal cortex which
controls amongst other things emotions
and inhibitions
that makes a lot of sense
okay so the idea that we only use 10 of
our brains is definitely not accurate
meaning there will never be some kind of
limitless style magic pill that turns us
all into superhumans overnight
but wait a second
what about the strange case of willie
and james cedars
isn't it a hell of a coincidence that
the originators of this weird 10 percent
of the brain myth
managed to raise a child who some claim
had the highest iq in the history of
mankind
well
yes
it kind of is
but then there are a few caveats to
william's story that i should probably
mention
the first is that some of those claims
made about him are a little
controversial for example there are
conflicting reports about just how high
his iq was
and it's generally accepted that his
family were prone to exaggerate some of
his more impressive feats of intellect
his sister once told a journalist that
her brother spoke every language on
earth
which seems
unlikely
cedis did indeed attend harvard at the
age of 11
but don't forget his godfather was one
of the university's most influential
professors at the time
so it's safe to say that probably helped
having said all that whilst we can't be
sure exactly how brilliant william cedis
was
what isn't in question is that he was
brilliant
even if his godfather did use his
influence to get william accepted into
harvard at such a young age there's no
doubt he wowed his professors when he
got there in his first year just before
he turns 12
william delivered such a stunning
lecture to the harvard mathematical club
on four-dimensional bodies and it wasn't
long before leading figures at the
university were predicting that william
would go on to become one of the
greatest mathematicians of the century
so whilst modern neuroscience tells us
that boris cedus and william james
can't possibly have helped william cetus
tap into some hidden brain power
not accessible to the rest of us
it does seem like they managed to do
something
and here perhaps we come to the kind of
secret truth that lies behind this odd
10 percent of your brain power myth
you see
boris cedus and william james never
claims that humans only use 10 of their
brain power
what they actually believed was that
most of us only ever achieve a tiny
fraction of our true potential
and
on that front
they were almost certainly correct
think about all the things in your life
that compete for your attention social
media the internet in general
tv school or work family friends hobbies
hopes fears dreams romance
now just imagine all the things you
could learn and the skills you could
master if you cut all of that out of
your life and spent every waking hour
studying training and practicing various
different things
with that kind of dedication over the
span of a human life
how many languages could you learn how
many instruments could you master
how many subjects could you become an
expert in
the human brain doesn't really seem to
have a limit on its ability to learn new
things the only thing holding it back is
our willingness to dedicate the time to
feeding it
whilst the exact methods used in raising
william cetus are mostly unknown we do
know that his father boris and william
james
designed a rigorous forced learning
program for william to follow from
practically the day he was born most of
us spent our childhoods playing with
toys and picking our noses william
cedars
he spent his training to become a genius
but before you go emptying your life of
all distractions to take up studying 24
hours a day
i should probably point out that
william's story
is also a cautionary one
this was a boy who never really got a
proper childhood he was sent to
university when he was still just a kid
and whose parents seemed determined to
raise a gifted son no matter the cost
and it turns out that whilst all of that
might give you a good shot at harvard it
isn't all that great for your mental
health
in the end none of the predictions about
cedars spectacular future in mathematics
came true
he didn't make any grand discoveries or
solve any of mankind's long-held
problems he didn't dazzle the world with
brilliant proofs or leaps of logic
in fact he didn't do much of anything
besides obsessively collect street car
transfers
he shunned academia altogether
working menial jobs that required no
intelligence whatsoever and having at
least one run-in with the law
before dying of a cerebral hemorrhage at
the age of just 46.
so yeah
there's no truth to the rumor that we
humans only ever use 10 of our brains
and whilst there is some truth to the
idea that few of us ever reach our full
potential
maybe that's not such a bad thing after
all life isn't actually one giant
competition to see who can achieve the
most stuff
even if it kind of seems like it is
sometimes
thanks for watching